day of talks The ifml Joint Simon's mini
Workshop here
um
thanks to Kalani for helping organize
everything and for
Sanjay and she
standing for letting us get together and
um you know people ask me uh what is
ifml so briefly I think everyone here
knows what it is but in case you weren't
at our annual report meeting
we just very brief stats last year we
had counting all the Publications from
all you know the work that ifml
supported we had 111 Publications with
two best papers in Europe
counted up 125 seminars that were
actually given as part of some
influences
supported 37 students
seven postdocs
you know we had a variety of workshops
and social events and trips so we'd like
to make these assignments every year if
you can
yeah so today we are having a workshop
for entrepreneur FML and the resident
program
the data driven decision process so this
morning you'll see three cars from sort
of learning slash optimization Theory
and in the afternoon we'll have three
talks from the data driven distribution
process broadly or econ PCS uh
stochastic networks so
um thank you range to learning for all
the help in organizing this and so this
is a workshop that Suchi Adam and me
coordinates okay just get started uh the
first Speaker today is uh survey goel
she said Microsoft research NYC and
going to you pencil thank you so much
for inviting me to give this talk
um and today I'm going to talk about
Transformer architectures and uh kind of
the representation properties I will
Define everything so that everybody's on
the page on the same page so feel free
to ask any questions and feel free to
stop me in the middle okay this is uh
based on joint work with some awesome
collaborators some of them are at
Microsoft research and some who passed
through as interns during my time at
Microsoft research
and here is one I always put some Dali
to prompt these days on um what
Transformers are doing these days so
this is a prompt on I just put an
Institute for foundations on machine
learning and It produced some cool art
artsy looking picture for this so I
thought this people would find
fascinating
I mean
you haven't given enough hats to people
yet
who said that our logo
okay so let me uh start so we all know
that in the last uh five years five or
so years of attention-based architecture
especially Transformers have become
really popular and they've seen
applications starting from national
language uh to like symbolic mathematics
Vision reinforcement learning even in
biology automated programming and this
list goes on and on as people find new
new and new ways to use these
architectures so one crucial thing about
these architectures is that they remove
these previous Notions of uh things that
we used to use which were convolutions
and recurrence and they added this new
notion of self-attention I'll describe
what self-attention is
um so the question that we wanted to
understand was that these architectures
that we used before convolutions and
recurrence kind of encoded some prior
beliefs that we had about the data that
we were processing so for example in
cnns we wanted to model some sort of
translational invariance and with the
rnns or any recurrent architecture we
were trying to model recurrent uh
structure in the data in a sequence to
sequence modeling data so Transformers
here kind of remove these things so it
wasn't clear what kind of inductive bias
these Transformers were adding into our
architecture so this is the overriding
question of this talk what kind of
functions do these Transformers
represent so if we look back at the
intuitions and The Guiding principles
that people came up with while they were
designing these architectures so from
the original paper this is a quote that
is from the original paper that these
architectures were intended to capture
these shorter pathlands between
long-range dependencies so they wanted
to capture these long-range dependencies
in a fashion that all of them were
simultaneously captured instead of in
recurrent when you do one at a time so
they were hoping that they can find
shorter path lines between these bigger
longer dependencies
uh some other work from the vision space
suggested that this has some like a more
relaxed or weaker or softer inductive
bias compared to CNN's because CNN's
you're fixing uh the window that you're
looking at but here this window is kind
of open-ended you can the the algorithm
the architecture can learn what window
to focus on
and then there's a lot of work trying to
understand what kind of functions these
uh
architectures are learning for example
there's this whole area of botology
which kind of tries to decipher from
attention heads like what kind of
structures they're learning so for
example here these are like chain bird
models and these are heads that you can
interpret to say that they're doing some
natural language task and this is
another uh one uh from an RL application
of these Transformers and you can see
there's some kind of structure of how
how they're looking back so these are
like attention maps are kind of like
what part of the text you're looking at
in the history so something that's
observed commonly is that these
attention weights which I'll describe
what they are exactly tend to be of
these two modalities that either they're
very sparse which you can see from here
even these red edges are sparse or they
are sort of uniform so they look at
everything together so this kind of two
modalities exist
and from a mathematical perspective if
you want to quantify uh such properties
of these architectures uh the standard
way to look at this is like we can think
of this as a function class F so here uh
this is the function class of
Transformers and then you can ask this
question about uh the capacity of this
function class so how rich is this
function plus how many functions are
there in this class and like how many
samples do you need to learn this
function class then you can ask a
representation question that given the
capacity is somewhat bounded then what
kind of interesting functions are there
in this function class and lastly you
can ask the hardest question here that
uh finally you're training these models
with radiant based optimization
algorithms and what kind of functions do
they actually learn
okay so with that I'm gonna start um
today's talk I'm going to start with the
Transformers 101 so I'll describe
exactly what this architecture is uh
then I will uh talk about the
representation power of a single uh
component of this Transformer
architecture and then I will talk about
the representation power of shallow uh
Transformers and then I'll end with some
questions uh that I'm still thinking
about
so let's start with Transformers 101 so
Transformers are sequence to sequence
models so they take in uh input which is
uh T tokens of D Dimension each so you
can think of a sentence as a tln
sentence and then each of uh these words
in this sentence can be thought of as a
vector in some D dimensional space so
here x 1 x 2 x 6 and this you can think
of some word embedding so taking these
words into some embedding space and what
you want to Output is another sequence
of tokens so you want to Output you want
to process them somehow that you get a
new embedding such that this embedding
now has context of what was in the
sentence so before you just started with
some embedding which is independent of
each words and now you want the new
embedding that somehow depends on what
is in the sentence so if you look at
this particular word you want this
word's output to have some relation and
the ways to do that is like you want to
find some weights that this word assigns
to every other word so you can think of
these as the weights and you want to sum
these weights up with with the features
of these words and get the new embedding
so this is uh what the attention network
is trying to do and these things you can
think of as attention weeks because
these are kind of Weights that you're
how much are you attending to another
word in the context
okay so now the question is how do you
actually generate these weights and so
the transformative architecture does it
in the following fashion so first it
computes these pairwise scores so
between every word so I'm just focusing
on this words embedding right now so it
computes the score function between this
word and any other word in the context
so this would be score X1 X4 X2 X4 and
so forth and for every different word
you would have these pairwise scores
okay so once you have this course uh
generally so on the right I'm just
showing what the exact Transformer
architecture does but you can have any
kind of score function that you want uh
for this generality uh for the
Transformer uh it's just a DOT product
of linear functions
and once you have these scores uh these
are unnormalized so uh these are passed
through a soft Max uh to get these
normalized score weights and then the
embedding is averaged with these weights
and this is the only place note that
you're having a global interaction
because these are all pairwise
interactions so here are the softmax
kind of adjusts the how much you should
care about each word by normalizing
these scores okay so so this is
basically one attention self-attention
head that you compute and here on the
right if you see these are all the
parameters that the ones in red are the
ones that are learned so it's learned
end to end and you train all the Red
parameters
okay so one thing if you've noticed this
architecture has is that if I shuffle
any of permute any of these coordinates
and I permute the output it doesn't
really change so it's not really
accounting for the position of where
everything lies uh by the structure that
it has so one thing that's commonly done
is that there's a positional encoding
that's added to each of these positions
and uh this this kind of ensures that
there's some positional information of
how the context is created
okay any questions on this
so that's just one head at the bottom
yeah so you get basically you can use
these same parameters so these are just
uh fixed parameters you can generate for
each of the different words you'll get
this embedding so they create different
the score function will evaluate to
different things for different uh words
and you'll get them ready but this
creates one layer of this
um let me show you so the so this
basically generates this but in practice
uh what you do is you take multiple of
these attention heads then you
concatenate them you can add and
normalize them you get your output then
you apply like a fully connected layer
which is the same one that's applied to
each of them so it's like shared across
so it doesn't add any dependencies
between
um the the tokens and you can apply this
many many times you can if you want to
do a supervised learning task you can
learn a leaner classifier at the end and
get a label or so forth whatever you
want to do with the sequence to sequence
models so this is the entire
architecture that I'm going to focus on
there are other many other things that
happen uh but this is what I'm going to
focus on any questions
I think this is figure out which
peer-wise correlations are important or
yeah yeah so the soft Max will kind of
wait so some pairwise correlations will
be more more larger than the other ones
so the softmax will kind of put more
weight on them and so you're going to
take in your new embedding so
yeah so here these weights will be
larger so in this like say this is this
weight is larger so this feature
corresponding to this will have more of
an impact here
so that's what kind of model what is
relevant in the context
yeah okay so uh so here I showed you
what self-attention was and uh then I I
talked about what token that these
Implement token by speed forward less
this will be important later in the day
so let me start with the main results of
trying to understand what these uh
single self attention heads do
and uh the question the first question
that we'll ask is what is the capacity
of this class of attention heads and how
many samples do you need to learn them
this is a completely statistical
perspective not enough uh not a not a
computational perspective so the first
uh result we have here is that if you
use an ocean of covering numbers as the
capacity measure then the number of
samples that you need to guarantee
uniform convergence uh is of the
following form so there's a polynomial
dependence on Norms so these are the
Norms of the parameters that you bound
and there's a logarithmic dependence on
the sequence length which is the length
of the number of tokens that you had so
the t uh here and the error being
Epsilon Square
so note that the sample complexity has
this sparse L1 regression kind of uh uh
complexity because there's a logarithmic
dependence on the input sequence there
so this uh this cannot represent
functions that are very rich uh in the
input sequence
and generally you can handle like other
kind of attention mechanisms and general
choices of these functions that I
mentioned before
so yeah
uh yeah so uh let me just show you the
next uh point so so here's the one thing
to notice that um if you would look at
the architecture you're sharing the same
weights across so the number of
parameters here is actually only d
square so the number of parameters does
not depend on T but you can show that if
you don't Mount the Norms of these
attention heads then even if your
dimension is three you require uh log T
samples to guarantee uniform convergence
so you can shatter uh log T points
so this capacity of this class is larger
than number of parameters if I don't
bound the
um Norms of the parameters here
uh so actually for this we need just uh
t-square I think
so it's polynomiality I'm not sure this
is tight so I don't know if you can do
better than this so you can construct
this log t uh chattering and it's like
some some simple construction some
circular circular construction that you
can get so for every uh every t i can
construct a you know log T points T
points that can be shattered but I don't
know if that's tight you can do better
or not
remind me again why there's a number of
printers
wait let me go back from this because
otherwise
so here note that the embedding is all
in D Dimension yeah and then you are
Computing scores which you are taking uh
you're taking a linear map on this D
dimensional output and you're taking a
linear map on another D Dimension output
and taking the dot product so this is
only a d cross D
um Matrix WK and WQ
actually and then this the waiting comes
from the soft Max the softmax combines
these t or t scores and then uh like
scales them but the coefficients of the
soft math they're T coefficients yeah
they're T coefficients there are two
parameters there
um I mean the the the number of
parameters that you're training I will
need oh you're not training
the alphas are computed based on the
scores right I'll pass the score through
a soft Max and then I'll get the answer
so why do I expect any dependence on G
yeah so you might not expect an
independence on T but if you don't Mount
the nons uh that the lower bound that I
showed you
like this
yeah so if you don't Mark the Norms you
can actually show that because of this
attention mechanism it's not a linear
function it has like some non-linearity
you can actually shatter uh points that
are depend on T even if your dimension
is three so the number of parameters
that you're you are you're using is only
nine here
but you can chatter more points
okay and the reason is because uh what
what what happens is in this
construction is that uh you have uh okay
you have these attention weights these
are tension weights you can design such
that you can pick out uh each of the
token based on different parameters and
so they're T tokens so you can pick out
these three different tokens for
different inputs and so that gives you
power
yeah
note that I'm already using three
dimensions so I can use I just use a
position encoding in two dimensions and
uh the value in one dimension so I just
need three dimensions
uh it's not growing with tea so because
I
on a unit circle I just take points on
the uh on the units of the uniformly
distributed
so yeah I think if you talk about uh bit
precision and all yeah you have some
Independence there
okay uh so now that we know that the
capacity is bounded does this actually
represent interesting functions uh so
what you can show is that if you talk
about Boolean functions then this can
approximate arbitrary as far as Boolean
functions with Norm scaling as a
function of sparsity and log T so
um I mean it's the question is how you
can map a Boolean functions into this uh
this feature Space by mapping your bits
into this uh this sequencer token
sequence so way to do this is that you
can take your input you can take an
embedding for each bit so bit bit 0 can
be mapped to one embedding and bit one
can be mapped to another embedding and
then you can add this positional
encoding and this this fixed position
encoding and that can map your uh
Boolean function into this language of
sequence to sequence models and you can
do this with a trainable position
embeddings and other ways without
positioning encoding also
um so this might address raghu's
questions if you don't have position
encoding you can still kind of map if
you have enough Dimension you can map
any Boolean function into that language
by assigning a token for each position
basically
so I can have a vocabulary that is log T
sized but then I can if this this
position is bit one then that token
appears in the text or not uh so with
emitting Dimension uh something that's a
function of log T you can get to
represent all sparse Boolean functions
in this setting
so even though the capacity is
controlled you can still represent
interesting functions in this class
uh so the idea is that your
self-attention can help you pick out the
relevant tokens so you can assign a lot
of weight on the relevant tokens and
then the fully connected net can
Implement any arbitrary function on the
selected tokens now the selected tokens
are only s so this this function can
have like normal as large as two to the
uh of s because there are that many
functions that exist
okay so attention is promoting sparsity
but uh the the fully connected net is
doing the heavy lifting of actually
Computing the function
another thing that you might notice that
this function class can do is that it
can focus uniform attention so if it
puts all the parameters as Zero by
giving everything equal weight it can do
a uniform averaging also so this is the
other modality that this function class
can compute
okay so together taking these two
together uh so we said the capacity is
uh of this form and we can represent any
esparz Boolean function uh with this
Norm bound so combining this you can get
that the these classes can learn sparse
functions as statistically near optimal
sample complexity which is a function of
uh the sparsity and poly logarithmic in
T and the interesting thing is the
number of parameters that you need are
only poly log uh t for this
so you don't need T number of parameters
to do that
so this week a call like this has like
the sparse variable bias that each uh
attention here is creating some sparse
variable in the input
so you can think of these as small small
Norm attention heads are like some
Computing some concise simple Gates of
uh of your circuit
with a good sample complexity
any questions
[Music]
so think about the input dimension
and this is the sparsity
okay then uh let me explain why such a
thing happens and uh the reason we say
is that uh highlighters that the softmax
has this two nice properties so it has
these two phases one is that it's really
smooth as a function so this property
holds that there's an L1 L Infinity
smoothness which means that if I put up
uh all the
um inputs off to the soft Max the L1
Norm which is a which is a distance
between t things only depends on the max
of the change between uh any of the
parameters so this gives us uh this
really smooth function which allows us
to capacity control because now this L1
distance change can be bounded by only
an L Infinity change in the input so
this allows us to get this log T
dependence and the other thing that
softmax has this exponential saturation
which means that if I put a lot of mass
in One Direction then it really gets
close in L one distance to that
direction so if E1 is the indicator for
the first coordinate then if I put c
times E1 in the soft Max then it goes
exponentially fast to picking up that
coordinate so I need Norms uh to for
token selector I need Norms only
logarithmic in t to be able to actually
select a token so these two facts of
soft Max being very smooth and also
acting as a selector helps do this task
okay then you can ask what happens when
you actually try to train these in
practice so we try to train simple
sparse Boolean Gates and this is a very
simple function you learn a three-way
end of T bit input so this is just what
the label is just the X1 so we choose
three indices randomly and then the
label is just the product of these
indices and this is what we found so
this is on the x-axis is the sequence
length and the y-axis is the number of
samples that that was needed by this
Transformer to learn and note that this
is on the log scale so this kind of
looks like linear in that log scale so
even for sequence length about a
thousand only about 100 samples roughly
110 samples were needed to actually
train this so it can actually train in
this low sample regime and uh this
statistical threshold is they're
consistent with lofty even even if you
train the position embedding so if you
train position embeddings those are
actually T cross D dimensional even then
uh it actually works and you can see
that the attention weights actually pick
out the relevant coordinates so they are
actually learning uh which coordinates
to look at
uh so we tried both the trained or so
one thing you can do is just take two
random orthogonal like somewhat
orthogonal vectors so that is one
embedding you can fix or you can even
train the entire uh embedding Matrix so
you can just have like two tokens you
can train these tokens
uh support
oh so I don't have it in the stock but
parity also works uh so it doesn't work
in the simple sample complexity it
doesn't work with very small sample
complexity only in very small T it works
but if you do an online uh fashion like
your online uh gradient descent it
actually learns parity and actually many
architectures learn about it
they require uh into the case steps to
do it
okay uh so any questions on this part
before I go to how to use this intuition
to actually say what more uh like
shallow Transformers actually do
yeah so the main case yes I mean it
seems like some of the key things you
talked about were just properties of
soft Max yeah so like why why you know
if you're given this talk and just show
me like a bunch of MLPs
I would have thought oh okay the same
thing happens but it doesn't so I mean
there's something else going on yeah so
that's special right the fact that there
is the same parameter
that's all all functions so there's only
D parameters now if I actually put a
fully connected net with t parameters
then I would have a much much richer
complexities and the softmax will not be
able to smooth it out so there's this
like nice uh fact that there's a
supervised score that is being repeated
and it's passed through a soft match
that helps us uh get this
otherwise yeah if I put like more and
more and more parameters I can't
guarantee anything
so the structure is very important
and even if instead of the pair device I
could have more I mean I could have more
parameters but just you know about norms
and so weight changes
you should actually get that in the
structure so here uh what happens is
okay so
if you see here you get this property of
the sofa Max so now you need to cover uh
this particular quantity which is the
distance that it moves so here the good
part is because they are all shared the
same parameters are shared I can only
have to cover a matrix that's only D
cross D dimensional and it's it's
Subspace so if all these parameters were
different then I would actually get
covering something that that has three
different parameters so that uh really
helps in the capacity so otherwise yeah
otherwise you can actually Express many
Rich functions if you allow for
everything
activities
okay let me uh probably attached to the
second part so uh one thing I pointed
out that these uh architectures also let
go of recurrent uh structure right so
there's no weight sharing across layers
and they only usually in practice are
only few a few layers deep like maybe 10
or 12. uh so we thought about like how
how can they actually learn and they
seem to be doing really well on uh
logical tasks so they seem to be
learning some record Dynamic so we
looked at this perspective of uh
learning uh uh pre-sequence to sequence
problems where you have an input of
sequence tokens uh Sigma one to Sigma T
and the output is a sequence of states
such that the state is basically
generated from the previous uh State and
the input total so this is just a simple
finite semi-automator that we look at
and we try to see that if Transformers
can learn uh this kind of function class
given that they have no reference
structure at all
and so for some examples of these are uh
you can think of these as uh these are
very simple ones so parity counter so it
can compute parity uh of uh given the
sequence the state can be the output of
the parity bit it can also do some
memory operations which is like it can
allow in whatever the previous memory
that it should previous time the memory
was set and it should just output that
something's more complicated from
reinforcement learning it can predict
which state you are given given an
action sequence so these models are
pretty uh structures are very general in
language for Generation reinforcement
learning and control and so the question
we ask is can shallower Transformers
with no record instruction Dynamics and
what you can show is that Transformers
can represent these uh semi-automator
with shortcut Solutions so they require
only depth little of T much less than
the recurrent depth that's needed and uh
so you get all order log T depth for all
so for a certain class of semi-automator
you can get uh poly in the state size
and then for sperm special classes of
automata you can actually get even
constant depth Solutions and these have
analogies to Circuit complexity for
different circuits so these
constructions are kind of inspired by
Circuit complexity constructions but
they fit really well for the Transformer
architecture and I'll just quickly show
you uh why uh so the these constructions
require basically boils down to
Computing two kinds of automata so one
is module accounting which is uh just
counting modulo some number and the
second is a memory lookup which is like
looking back at the sequence and finding
the last the closest position where you
set your value and these two and then
combining these two together and the
good part about this these two functions
is that these fit very much into the
attention framework that I described
before for example the module accounting
can just be done by doing a uniform
attention on everything and taking a
modulo p so this is just taking the sum
mod P and the memory lookup can be done
using this pass attention because it
only has to find which closest position
it has to look at so this is a sparse
attention head so with very few
parameters you can Implement uh these
constructions because all you need to
implement is these two functionalities
and with even more properties of
attention which which is the
self-attention you can actually
Implement even shorter uh Solutions uh
for these problems and I'll just uh and
uh since I'm running out of time to show
that in practice actually we try to
train Transformers to solve all these uh
tasks on these semi or semi-automator
and in fact they do do this in
um very very low depth so if you here
you can see the layers and the accuracy
that you're getting so very fast uh you
can get like 99 accuracy with very few
layers so they actually uh train in
practice and they do learn attention
patterns very similar to what we showed
where they either do uniform attention
or they pick out these parts coordinates
that they should look at and in fact uh
these are shortcut Solutions in the
sense that they don't actually
generalize outside of the length that
you train them and whereas a recurrent
solution would clearly uh work even if
you increase the length of the sequence
so these actually learn these brittle
shortcut Solutions
so I'm gonna end uh we're just uh saying
that uh in terms of theory there are a
lot of interesting questions because uh
this computational model of
self-attention is not very well
understood it can give you gains that
are uh surprising that are not uh not
understood very well like these these
shortcut Solutions and we can understand
these self-attention heads better and in
terms of experiments uh these synthetic
control setups of like looking at
semi-automata or Boolean functions
actually gives a lot of insights into
how these uh architectures induce and uh
you know have inductive biases how they
learn features and other things there's
a lot of line of work that's starting to
uh focus on looking at these uh
synthetic setups inspired by by
theoretical uh models and studying these
architectures so I'll end with thanking
my collaborators and I'll take any
questions thank you
foreign